alors qu'ils me vous remplacer en cas et
franchement je dois dire que vous êtes
encore plus jolie que en cas enfin du
moins à mon goût alors kim 80 59 85 vous
quand il donne la moitié des portables à
mon éthique on appelle ça alors vous
êtes vietnamienne vous avez 25 ans vous
êtes une amie diren et de 1 km et de
kewell depuis depuis une longue date
voilà alors vos cheveux vos yeux blancs
sont étonnants et des manches et une
vietnamienne mais c'est le résultat d'un
clonage vous avez un clonage avec un
santon brebis comme si c'est la cousine
de devenir
ben vous avez dansé un clonage c'est
quoi ma grand mère dans la guerre
d'indochine a vu qu'une histoire d'amour
avec un militaire français et ça a sauté
une génération se demande toujours à
quoi ça va servir à gardanne oshima
voilà pour les groupes cette manie si
oui on dirait un truc est retouché au
photoshop
pardon
que veut dire non qui la met dans la
merde peu ce qui vous êtes célibataire
pas pour longtemps j'ai toujours dit un
truc on va toujours toujours dit le jour
je rencontre à une vietnamienne blonde
aux yeux bleus
je l'épouserais c'était pas ça le
dernier mot la phrase était bien non
c'est incroyable non ce qui est
incroyable c'est que toute sa famille
son bras avec les étirer ses ils ont
vraiment une qu elle a vraiment grandi
dans une culture asiatique le dit mr
mien et il suit tout l'effet de vina
mais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
comment dit on mange en parlant en
vietnamien a comme maria tu ailles
concourir à haikou non il rate également
commandé des crevettes
alors alors
pour savoir si kim mérite de remplacer
en cas on va comparer vos réponses avec
celle d'en cas dans l'interview
kim est ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à vous déguiser en elton john ah
oui comme encas incroyable qui mus que
par amour vous seriez prête à vous
droguez non comment cas est-ce qu
apparemment vous auriez prête à prendre
17 kg qu'est ce qu'elle a répondu en cas
comme ça comme qui me l'a dit et alors
est ce que vous seriez pas ta femme 17
kg
non quand mon cas est ce que par aman
vous seriez prête attention
peut-être aller vivre à limoges pourquoi
du bouge parce que les voir tu vas voir
tu racontes facile donc la réponse est
dans mon cas oui comme un cas assez
incroyable c'est un clown vraiment
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer par
amour une femme oui comme encas
d'ailleurs je crois que là on assiste
vraiment à un sans faute je pense que
les a pas de est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à embrasser cent fois ses
chaussettes sales non sens fiscal
comment karanka répondu le mec qui me
demande ça il dégage tout de suite oui
c'est le cas c'est son côté elena
ceausescu est très est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à fréquenter les clubs
échangistes
comment cas c'est incroyable c'est
vraiment on a alors est-ce que par amour
vous soyez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
peut-être à beaucoup mieux au caire
avait du monde bien bien bien elle est
mieux d'accord pour être esclaves
sexuelles c'est bien correct dans la
chanson c'est important est-ce que par
amour ou seriez prête qui m'a accepté
quelques infidélités nantes où chaque
nation est sensible maman tu voulais
mais vit ça pour eux si ça peut rendre
un réseau de le coupe oui pourquoi pas
on sent la différence entre la
vietnamienne et la roumaine
c'est dire qu'en cas avait répondu
jamais et vous vous êtes prêtre c'est
bien vous êtes plus maligne c'est bien
j'ai tout compris vous allez garder
longtemps tirs hier dix ans
vous adore
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu